a large number of President Abraham
Lincoln's personal possessions have
survived more than 150 years after his
death many are on display at the Lincoln
Presidential Library and Museum in
Illinois including his official
presidential seal but that and other
items may be sold off to help the
museum's foundation pay a significant
debt Adriana Diaz shows us some of the
priceless artifacts that could go to the
highest bidder in your honor good
morning good morning 15-hundred
artifacts that changed hands through
time were eventually bought by a private
collector
they finally entered the public sphere
in 2007 when the museum's foundation
bought the collection for twenty-three
million dollars but the loans due next
year and their millions short at the
Lincoln Presidential Library and Museum
in Springfield Illinois and she
delivered to Abraham Lincoln's legacy
that all men are created equal is alive
it's amazing
but some of Lincoln's most prized
possessions are in peril like his hat
gloves quillpen and a fan that belonged
to his wife Mary they may go to auction
because of a historic debt what I
sometimes say is he couldn't catch a
break in the 19th century and it seems
now he can't catch a break in the 21st
century dr. Carlin arouse key runs the
museum's private foundation which is
more than nine million dollars short on
a twenty three million dollar loan used
to buy Lincoln artifacts the monies due
next year and one way to get the money
fast auction off Lincoln's belongings
may I go in please do illinois state
historian Sam wheeler let us into their
high-security vault where we keep the
greatest treasures that we treasures
that could be sold include Wow that's
not what I was expecting was that fur
it's beaver fur Lincoln's iconic hat as
people called out
good evening mr. Lincoln he donned that
cap and that's what you think those two
marks are on the brim from well-worn
fingerprints also at risk this wanted
poster from Lincoln's assassination in
1865 that's from the collection too and
the gloves that were in his pocket that
ill-fated night that's his blood right
there yes oh my goodness
here in here I've seen people stand in
front of the bloody gloves
stand in front of the stovepipe hat and
the weep because that's a physical
connection they have with the greatest
president in American history to save
these items arouse key hopes private
donations pour in what do you say to
folks who say that your organization
shouldn't be depending on the public to
save it to bail it out we would
encourage them to not view it as a
bailout but rather as an opportunity to
give back to the man who's done so much
for us is this part of the collection
that's at risk yes this is she says the
financial crisis is partly to blame
because donations declined somebody's
got some splainin to do but that's not
enough for Tony Lyon a Lincoln buff who
once sat on the board that oversaw the
museum we really don't have any serious
accounting of how much they raise every
year
and how much they spend do you think
this has reached the level of a scandal
yes I really do
was there any mismanagement of funds
that led you to this mess
not any mismanagement of funds if you're
able to raise the money how will you
feel oh my god it'll be the scream that
went around the world they have to
decide whether to go to auction and
which items to sell in the next few
months they've even started a GoFundMe
page which has raised more than seven
thousand dollars but that's a long way
from the nine point seven million they
still owe I mean what's the starting bid
on the Hat I want in well the Hat is me
twofer so you might like that but they
said you know the hats one item but if
they sell that maybe they could get all
the money but they really want to
preserve the Hat so they don't want it
they don't want it to get there well the
Hat is a national treasure there are so
many gloves very wealthy Americans I'm
thinking that the like prized pieces of
history like this like Bill Gates David
Rubenstein Paul Allen I mean others that
I'm sure should would be interested in
weighing in that's what the museum hopes
they hope that some high net worth
people might help them out or even
smaller donations could help and this
isn't some cut-rate president either
this is you know names you know you know
you may have heard of him right exactly
this isn't the Andrew Johnson we'll keep
us posted
although the Andrew Johnson's snuff box
I'm sure is an interesting piece of
historical or kanna Adriana thank you as
always